were you ever like big into video games
was that ever a kid sure I used to I
played asteroids when I got into the
newspaper for playing for ten hours on
an arcade game a Super Bowl 13 though
that's where the blink started yeah no
they were there before I think I would
have played for 24 hours it was just the
losing ships it was 80 it was a Super
Bowl 1981 the 49ers and the Bengals in
the Superbowl and I played there any out
there all did that bother that left oh
wow somebody somebody replaced the
picture of you with the person that was
oh man that's my first press the guy had
the same glasses I was 13
Wow Nick DiPaolo told me I look like
Adrian from rocky the [ __ ] hat
concentratin was concentration was
written all over a 13 year-old Jimmy
Norton's face as he strove to keep the
world safe from asteroids and to win
himself a place in the Guinness Book of
World Records you were in the book no
but that was striving to oh you didn't
get it I did not so what I did you stop
what happens
I just lost chips I mean Charles Nikola
was a former North Brunswick mayor who
operated the arcade uh-huh it was like
the hot it was I've always called was
the name of the arcade the Playhouse
arcade [ __ ] yeah man it was uh man and
the Brunswick shopping center and I just
lost four point eight million I went
through 480 ships and the ironic part is
these are a pic I wish there was a photo
of that entire page because I think I've
tweeted that out before but next to me
the photo next to me the story next to
me was Ozzie bit the head of a bat
really so cool that's incredibly won
over was a picture of Ozzie and how he
was in trouble that's awesome right off
a bat so what do you feel like I mean I
know you're only 13 years old but when
you sit there locked into that game for
11 hours or every 13 hours whatever you
say yeah from 1:00 p.m. it said until
like 11:30 at night when fatigue set in
the machine finally won when you walk
away from that system and go back into
real life what do you feel like you know
I don't remember you so long ago I I
know they were just a
I was used to people watching me play
that game like his that game I was
really [ __ ] good at so I was used to
people in the arcade if you were good at
a game would stand around so I was used
to having ten people watching me play
this video game John walks in ever since
I was young
damn so annoying I can't find the full I
still have one copy of it somewhere at
home yeah I found it recently did you
take your box of mementos that's where
it is that makes my newspapers the
essence the star the a home news did you
laminate it or anything cuz newspapers
like rot over time I should write a
paper yeah
laminate the page you should do like
what you used to do with baseball cards
like put it in the sleeves yeah you know
did you wake up that morning like you
know David Chapman you let go like
today's the day I wish there was a copy
of it by the way are there ways to see
old newspapers online earn your possible
you probably don't have all of them
loaded and you gotta go to your local
library and read it off a broomstick
remember those big like turning me like
that yeah was me and Ozzie I'm so
[ __ ] pissed I can't find it
yeah it was great it's awesome I wasn't
that mean I was kind of a fan but I was
like yeah I was a kiss fan still can you
go to the bathroom if they just keep on
yeah but you run over I would piss and
lose a few ships but you might lose say
ten ships while you're pissed but I had
150 ships right like you're gonna for
you you had to
I got enough bathroom ships you in the
bathroom yeah I didn't [ __ ] and I didn't
piss then like I do now I mean I had a
bladder how many ships do you have when
you realize this is ending like you have
a hundred fifty ships you're like I'm
gonna be playing as long as I could
possibly play like is it when you get
down to 15 you're like oh no at one
point like the coolest thing is when the
entire top of the screen like when you
got a new ship it looked like a try a
full triangle like that was the symbol
of an extra ship in asteroids uh-huh and
like you know you'd have your top three
in the right-hand corner you started
with three and then every 10,000 you get
an extra one so if you got to 80,000
without losing a ship you'd have 11
ships lined up in the top of the screen
but when you have like 20 or 30 across
the top and the entire ship the entire
top of the screen yeah was extra ships
and then when you lose one you wouldn't
see a click which meant that you had so
many they were off the screen that's
what that was cool
[ __ ] ships that's what yeah well you
realize you're losing when you start to
go deep you lose a ship and then you
start to see the space showing oh that's
that I realize yeah and then you down to
your lash you know and then you get one
you know you bent down to three and then
you pick one more is there a big crowd
around you when you were at one point
yeah at that point yeah it was [ __ ]
the newspaper came just wanted to let
you know that's so cushy a kill screen
there's a kill screen coming up there's
a kill screen there wasn't that culture
though I mean maybe it was I just wasn't
aware everybody's just a beginning this
is this was the beginning of yeah 1981 I
mean it was fun there was still that
culture cuz pac-man fever was in the 80s
yes I mean no no it was popular but it
wasn't like I didn't have any access to
it right no way to share I guess it
existed on some level I don't know
without social media and all this stuff
bringing us together that's when a holo
is a hello that's right back when Iowa
and everybody looking down at their
phones all this just a good arty [ __ ]
yourself one more Jim and Sam catch up
with full episodes and interviews from
celebrity guests anytime on demand using
the Sirius XM atom